president Trump prepares to assume the
bully pulpit to push for his border wall
Democrats declare President Trump an
unprecedented threat to the Constitution
and Whoopi Goldberg has some pooping
advice for Alexandra Ocasio Cortez I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
I mean if me pitching Whoopi go over
talking about bowel movements with
Alexander Ocasio Cortez isn't enough to
hook you in today's show I just don't I
don't know what it's we have a lot of
good stuff coming up for you here today
a lot of bad stuff too so basically just
a lot of stuff and we will get to all of
it in just one second first let's talk
about the fact you're losing your hair I
know you've been in denial you've been
looking in the mirror and thinking no I
look just as fulsome up top as I used to
except now you don't you're starting to
look like your father and this is why
you need keeps losing your hair stinks
you don't realize how much you care
about it until you start losing it which
is why you should be using keeps the
easiest and most affordable way to keep
the hair that you have these FDA
approved products used to cost so much
but now thanks to keeps they're finally
inexpensive and easy to get for five
minutes now and a buck a day you're not
gonna have to worry about hair loss
again getting started with keeps is
really easy sign up takes less than five
minutes just answer a few questions and
snap some photos of your hair a licensed
physician will review your information
online and recommend the right treatment
for you and then it is shipped directly
to your door every three months keeps
offers generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there you've heard of them before
but you probably never gotten them for
this price it's only ten bucks to 35
bucks a month plus now you get your
first month for free one hell of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair to receive
your first month of treatment for free
go to keeps calm / Ben that is ke EPS
calm / Ben once again free month of
treatment it keeps calm / Ben keeps hair
today hair tomorrow ke EPS calm / Ben
for a free month of treatment go check
it out right now okay so the big news
today of course is that the President of
the United States is going to give an
oval office address tonight as I
recommended last week on this show
now you remember go back listen to the
rewind last week I said to President
Trump that he should give an oval office
address and he should explain to the
American people exactly why the
government is shut down because
everything has been filtered through the
lens of a highly partisan brutal media
that sees everything President Trump
does as deeply and inevitably awful
Trump needs to go directly to the
American people and force Democrats to
defend their position that walls aren't
inherently bad according to the
Associated Press that's exactly what
President Trump is slated to do tonight
with no breakthrough in sight
President Donald Trump will argue his
case to the nation on Tuesday that a
crisis at the us-mexico border requires
the long and invulnerable wall he's
demanding before ending the partial
government shutdown hundreds of
thousands of federal workers face missed
paychecks on Friday as the shutdown
drags through a third week worth
remembering all
those people will be paid back pay as
soon as the shutdown ends which
inevitably it will in the next couple of
weeks
Trump's oval office speech his first as
president will be followed by a visit
Thursday to the southern border to
highlight his demand for a barrier White
House press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders tweeted that he will use the
visit to meet with those on the front
lines of the national security and
humanitarian crisis again optics does
matter the president going and meeting
with Border Patrol agents who want to
see a wall down there is a ringing
rebuke to Democrats who keep claiming
that border patrol doesn't actually need
a wall that the wall is Border Patrol if
Border Patrol agents are telling the
president that they need more resources
and the president says we need more
resources that is a pretty good argument
the administration is also talking about
the idea of declaring a national
emergency to allow Trump to move forward
on the wall without Congress approving
leave 5.6 billion dollars that he was
vice president Mike Pence said that the
White House counsel's office is looking
at the idea now this is where I part
ways with the president I think this is
a very very bad idea I think it's an
immoral idea from a constitutional
perspective the president of the United
States is not giving unilateral power to
just start going around siphoning money
from one area of legislatively delegated
cash to another area of non
legislatively delegated cash this is a
really bad precedent and it's a really
bad policy the President of the United
States should not be declaring a
national emergency on the southern
border akin to a military emergency like
a military invasion that requires him to
go to the Defense Department coffers
open them up and then take money that
has been delegated for the building of a
base somewhere else and then say we I'm
gonna use it for a border wall now the
reason this is a bad idea is not just
because this is a congressional issue
and Trump should be forcing the
Democrats feet to the fire on this thing
the reason this is a bad idea is because
if Elizabeth Warren god forbid becomes
president or at some point in the future
in Alexander Ocasio Cortes becomes
president and then she declares that we
have a national climate emergency that
we ought to mobilize in the same way
that we've mobilized for wars in the
past of a national emergency and that
necessitates us taking the entire
Defense Department budget and plunging
it into windmills are we all going to
sit by and say you know what
national emergency requires that the
president has this sort of power the
answer of course is no the President
does not have this sort of power that
national emergency power was granted to
the president in a time of basically
foreign invasion specifically so that if
Congress did not have the ability to
prove the building of a base somewhere
in the middle of a war zone the
president could just go ahead and do it
if he needed to do it
it was meant to Adam bright it was meant
to make better and and make greater the
president's war powers as commander in
chief who was not meant to allow the
president to run roughshod over the
desires of Congress now Democrats
themselves are having a tough time
defending exactly why they feel about
the wall the way they feel about the
wall and they're struggling for an
answer they've relied heavily on a media
that hates President Trump just really
really despises President Trump the way
this is gonna work tonight is the
president Trump is going to give his
address and then that will immediately
be followed by some Democrat giving a
response address now
last night I was asking on Twitter
whether Republicans had had that
opportunity when Obama was president I
was answered by Dave waggle over at the
Washington Post that yes Republicans did
have that opportunity in 2011 President
Obama at that point spoke about deficit
reduction and then John Boehner was
given five minute response time to
respond in 2009 apparently Republicans
were given the same so this isn't
completely unusual Pelosi and Schumer
want equal airtime now equal airtime is
not exactly the same thing if Trump
speak for 45 minutes I don't think that
we have to hear Chuck Schumer speak for
45 minutes in response that's not what
the network's gave but having Democrats
issued their own response fine
I mean I'm honestly I am fine with the
idea of having Democrats have to spend
ten minutes explaining why their
position on the border is exactly the
same as ms-13 that seems like a win for
the President of the United States and
frankly it seems like a clarification of
the controversy in the country so
according to Pelosi and Schumer they put
out a letter right now and this letter
says now that the television networks
have decided to air the president's
address which is which if his past
statements are any indication will be
full of malice and misinformation
Democrats must immediately be given
equal airtime okay again been man for
equal airtime is silly Republicans were
not given that at least as best I can
recall during the Obama administration
but being put on the air seems fully
fitting and then they say the facts are
clear President Trump has the power to
stop hurting the country by reopening
the government and ending the Trump
shutdown Democrats in an increasing
number of Republicans in Congress have
repeatedly urged the president and
leader McConnell to end the Trump
shutdown and reopen the government while
Congress debates the president's
expensive and ineffective wall
unfortunately President Trump keeps
rejecting the bipartisan house-passed
bills which of all
received strong bipartisan support in
the Senate to reopen the government
instead he's still demanding the
American taxpayers pay at least 5.7
billion dollars for his wall which can't
pass either chamber of Congress and of
course Mexico is not paying for now that
the TV networks have decided to air the
president's address Democrats must be
given equal airtime okay well here's the
thing then that works because the
networks are farts and left basically
have agreed with the Democrats not on
giving them equal airtime but on the
notion that President Trump must be fact
checked in real time now this is
something they didn't do for Obama I
remember because I was there okay when
Obama gave his speeches on Obama care
which were chock-full of absolute
falsehoods like if you like your doctor
you can keep her doctor there were never
any Chiron's on the bottom of the screen
at CNN saying President Obama lies if
you like your doctor you can keep your
doctor or President Obama lies he wants
to lower the deficit and I remember any
of those fact checkers I remember there
are fact checks afterward from
organizations that do political fact
checks but there is no real-time
fact-checking by the TV networks but now
there's a lot of talk about how we need
this sort of real-time fact-checking
specifically for President Trump because
President Trump is such a liar now do I
think that this is because they really
believe that Trump is so much more of a
liar than Obama no I think this has a
lot more to do with the fact that it's
agree with President Trump if President
Trump were on the left then I think they
would be fine with President Trump
fibbing
take for example Allison Cameron over at
CNN so she says basically that the debt
that the the fact checkers at the
networks should spend their nights fact
checking everything President Trump says
I do not remember this sort of talk in
any lead up to any Obama lie told about
Obama care or about the border or about
any other issue here's Allison Cammarata
though prepping the groundwork for the
the media to claim that President Trump
is a vast liar
therefore trying to make his speech
ineffective tonight now the best thing
that the White House can do by the way
as I'll explain in just a second the
best thing that the White House can do
is to is to tell the truth as openly as
possible we'll talk about that in just a
second but here's Cammarata setting up
the combat which is not going to be
between Trump and the Democrats it's
gonna be between Trump in the media this
morning the fact checkers are eating
their Wheaties and getting extra rest
since they will be working overtime
tonight to separate fact from fiction
on this Porter situation I mean listen
to that kind of media coverage that's
objective media coverage the fact
checkers are getting ready for President
Trump to tell a bevy of lies how about
this how about you just back checking
right Howie just fact-checking about the
hysteria over your own journalistic
virtue for preparing to fact-check
I'm glad they finally woke up after
eight years of Obama I'm glad the fact
checkers ate their Wheaties and and woke
up like Rip Van Winkle after eight years
of going to into a complete coma when it
came to fact-checking
you can listen to the way that the media
are patting themselves on the back for
all of this brian Stelter who's the non
objective objective journalist at CNN
he's their so-called media watchdog he
quoted a guy named Brian Lowry who's a
senior editor over there he says this
two cents worth of analysis on this
issue Trump seldom experienced his clear
admonition for regularly spouting
falsehoods really he doesn't I'm unaware
of any Democrat for the last several
years who hasn't said that President
Trump lies a lot and by the way
President Trump does fib a lot a denying
him live unfiltered access as Brian
Lowry without some sort of screening or
vetting doesn't seem like an
unreasonable condition to impose under
the circumstances even if that means
facing his Twitter rap for it so CNN's
Brian Lowry doesn't even want CNN to air
this speech unless they have a CNN
chyron fact checker underneath Trump
speech and that's it that's asinine it's
insane you can do a retrospective fact
check I think that's fine although I
again I will acknowledge that I don't
think they did this during Obama's
tenure but better they should do it for
Trump and Obama than they should not do
it for either but the fact is that when
they say things like we should not air
the president's speech unless we have a
real-time fact checker on a split screen
explaining what President Trump is
saying that is wrong first of all that
assumes objectivity on the part of the
real-time fact checker that is not the
case
second when was this ever applied to
anyone on the other side of the aisle I
love that the media are preemptively
trying to take the teeth out of
President Trump speech because they know
it'll be effective right that's the real
problem for them they know that when the
president gets on national TV and he
says listen we have 60 to 80 percent of
the women who are crossing the southern
border have been sexually assaulted
according to studies that is a
humanitarian crisis we have terrorists
who are crossing that southern border
that's a crisis we have criminals who
are crossing that southern border that's
a crisis and we need a barrier and the
Democrats will pay for it
that that's a losing position
for the Democrats and so they're going
to try and undercut what the president
has to say with all this talk of
real-time fact-checking Stelter
continues by saying keep in mind most
Americans see right through the
president's tricks poll after poll shows
that most Americans do not trust him
that's why I'm skeptical any primetime
speech will have a serious effect but
worth noting polls also show that the
American people do not trust the media
okay we're gonna get to what Trump
should say tonight in just one second
first let's talk about how you maintain
your online privacy and security as a
public figure I'm constantly worried
about being a hacked or spied on I don't
want my emails compromised or my credit
card number or online banking passwords
stolen that happens to hundreds of
millions of people every year so how can
you protect yourself the answer is
Express VPN expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your connection by encrypting
100% of your network data hiding that IP
address that means nobody can record or
access your online activity download the
Express VPN app on your computer or
smartphone and then use the internet
just as you normally would you click one
button in the Express VPN app and voila
you are now protected expressvpn is
fantastic for accessing content from
anywhere they have VPN locations in 94
countries they have blazing fast speeds
there's a reason they're rated the
world's number one VPN service for
Internet users the nice folks over at
expressvpn have also extended special
pricing of less than seven bucks per
month to all my listeners so visit
expressvpn comm slash ben's to claim
your discount again that's expressvpn
comm slash mendel check it out right now
expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn more
that's expressed VPN comm slash frnd
keep our online activity safe no reason
to expose it to the world's worst people
Express VPN VPN com slash them okay so
the networks actually debated because
they don't like Trump this much the
networks actually debated whether or not
to even air this thing now remember this
is president Trump's first address to
the nation of his entire tenure and he
gave the State of the Union but he
hasn't had a direct to the people oval
office address ever this is his first
time which is why it's important Obama
used to do it all the time and the
networks aired it all the time until
they realized they weren't getting any
ratings off of it
he did one in January 2011 on Egypt he
did one in April 2011 announcing the
government shutdown deal he did one in
May of 2011 announcing the death of bin
Laden Michelle Malkin has an entire list
of these June 11 announcing a troop
drawdown in Afghanistan May 2012
announcing a troop withdrawal in
Afghanistan
April 2013 at Boston Marathon bombing
remarks September 2013 an address on
Syria
October 2013 August 2014 September 2014
and there more there he did two kids
like five of them in 2009 alone you did
one in February one in March one in
April one in July one in December right
so he was doing it just all the time and
the media constantly covered it and they
said well it's not a problem
he's the president we ought to give him
the airtime I love that the media
actually had to debate whether to give
the president airtime because they are
that afraid that the president is going
to say something effective that's really
what's going on here the media are
afraid the President of the United
States is going to say something that
actually works on the American people
and thus they're preemptively preparing
their fact checks now with that said
that means that the Trump administration
his speechwriting team should really
lock down every step they put in his
mouth okay he is going to be speaking
not off-the-cuff tonight he's gonna be
speaking from teleprompter that means
that everything they do should be
extraordinarily buttoned down
defensible with footnotes just take the
wind out of the sails of the Democrats
the Democrats would like to argue
Trump's honesty rather than arguing
Trump's policy that's the reality and so
President Trump ought to provide them
nothing but honesty tonight now here's
why this makes a difference the facts
themselves are strong enough that you
don't actually have to exaggerate okay
so the reason this came up is because
members of the administration made some
unsupportable claims about the terror
threat on the southern border so nichola
so chris wallace was on fox news on
sunday with sarah huckabee sanders and
sarah huckabee sanders had claimed
something like 40,000 people on criminal
and terror watchlist had crossed the
southern border or something and chris
wallace basically shellacked her over
and said this is an unsupportable claim
and and you can see how could be Sanders
struggling to give an answer the State
Department says that there is quote
their words no credible evidence of any
terrorists coming across the border from
Mexico we know that roughly nearly 4,000
known or suspected terrorists come into
our country illegally says there hasn't
been any Paris that they found coming
it's my land and it's spicy it's all of
the above the one thing that you're
forgetting is that the most vulnerable
point of entry that we have into this
country is our southern border and we
have to protect ok so when he says when
you say there are 4,000 terrorists
crossing in they're all coming in
through airports they're not coming in
through the southern border that's right
now here's the problem all of the
administration had to do was tell the
truth about how many terrorists were
coming across the southern border
because all the entity name is 1 right
all they have to say is the pretty
proper role of the United States
government on immigration is to prevent
any terrorists from entering and here's
what NBC News reports right they say US
Customs and Border Protection
encountered just six immigrants on
us-mexico border in first half of fiscal
year 2018 whose names run a federal
government list of known or suspected
terrorists according to border patrol
data obtained by NBC News now listen to
the phraseology there Customs and Border
Protection encountered just six
immigrants on us-mexico border in the
first half of fiscal year 2018 so in
other words one terrorist a month
basically was trying to cross on the
us-mexico border one terrorists a month
that sounds like a lot of terrorists to
me I'll be honest with you that sounds
like I mean again they're saying in just
the first half of 2018 six terrorists
attempted to do this and those were
known terrorists not unknown terrorists
and the number is probably larger it's
probably 10 or 12 well it only took five
illegal immigrant terrorists to actually
commit 9/11 all the others were here on
actual legal visas so why exactly would
we not take that seriously
NBC News explains the low number
contradicts statements by Trump
administration officials including White
House press secretary sarah huckabee
sanders who said on Friday that CBP
stopped nearly 4,000 known or suspected
terrorists from crossing the southern
border in fiscal year 2018 so in other
words this is the point that I'm making
with regard to the media the media would
rather argue over whether the Trump
administration is telling the truth than
they would argue over the issue itself
the issue itself and and it by the way
it's totally appropriate for them to
fact-check the Trump administration in
the same way it's totally appropriate
for the media to fact-check any
politician all politicians should be
fact check which demonstrates the
necessity of the Trump administration
really really really tonight sticking to
the facts they I've said this all along
about President Trump president Trump
lies a lot and it's bad he should stop
doing it because he
agenda does not require wise to support
it if your agenda requires a lie to
support it your agenda is bad if your
agenda can be based solely on truth in
fact then your agenda is fine the Trump
agenda is not a problem on the border he
should just tell the truth about it
ELISA Farah for example over at the VP's
office said it is 100% correct at 17,000
adults with a criminal record were
arrested in fiscal year 2018 at the
southern border as per border patrol
that's a good statistic 17,000 adults
with a criminal record arrested at the
border how many people are not being
arrested at the border with a criminal
record and we know that it's basically a
terrorist a month was caught at the
border by Border Patrol that those are
numbers that matter but this is why it's
important that the Trump administration
really stick to the facts not as much as
humanly possible just stick to the facts
that's all because the case is really
strong I take for example there's a
former ice director on Fox News and he
was saying listen we need some sort of
barrier on the wall this is Thomas
Holman the former US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement Acting Director he
implored Nancy Pelosi to consider taking
a federal funding deal that includes
money for a border wall because it's her
job to keep Americans safe as well Nancy
Pelosi you need to love your country a
little more and you hate this president
I mean you got your number one
responsibility to protect the Americans
and secure our border we've already
shown how a walk of war very can be
effective so put politics aside look
this is all politics they don't want
this president have a win on the border
but what they don't understand is the
president wins on this board issue
America wins America is more secure this
is the only issue that Republicans
should be hammering over and over and
over again this is what President rump
should hammer tonight and this is why
Democrats are actually afraid of this
oval office address you think they'd be
screaming like a stuck pig if they
weren't afraid of the oval office
address you think that they would be
making a fuss over fact-checking if they
thought this was a big nothing by the
end of the Obama administration every
time the man appeared on national TV
everybody just sort of sighed and one
and just went okay fine whatever dudes
talking again and then Obama would get
on I need talk and donkey talk and you
just say things lot of things and don't
pay attention well people know that
tonight lots and folks are gonna pay
attention to what President Trump has to
say and suddenly Democrats are going to
be forced to explain why they will not
give the president 11 hours worth of
federal funding to pay for a permanent
border solution along our southern
border the president can do some real
heavy lifting tonight
all he has to do is make sure he doesn't
undercut himself by saying things that
are that are factually dubious right
when the president went out this week
and he said that former presidents have
said they want a wall - and then we
couldn't find a former president he said
they wanted a wall that's exactly the
media wants to live in that space the
media wants to live in the space where
they can spend all the time not talking
about the agenda but talking about how
dishonest President Trump is Trump ought
not give them that opportunity this is
why a president with discipline would be
fantastic any sort of discipline please
so tonight stick to the teleprompter mr.
president no exaggeration just say
what's true and if you say what's true
the American people will hear you now
with all of that said Democrats are
seeking to to come up with some sort of
response and their response is pretty
weak tea I'll explain what exactly their
response is in just a second first let's
talk about your back so I will admit to
you that lately I've been having some
serious neck pains and serious neck and
back pain and one of the ways that I
alleviate this pain is by hopping on my
teeter inversion table with its heater
inversion table you use gravity in your
own bodyweight to decompress your your
spine and relieve pressure on your discs
and surrounding nerves decompressing on
a teeter inversion table for a few
minute today it's a great addition to
anyone's daily routine to maintain that
healthy spine and active lifestyle it
decompresses the spine it's really good
for my shoulders as well I've done my
homework
this is the best inversion table on the
market over three million people have
put their trust in the teeter inversion
table and right now they're offering a
great deal for my listeners and my
listeners only for a limited time you
can get the brand-new 2019 Teeter Fit
spine inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym teeter
inversion tables I'm telling you these
these folks have tons of five-star
reviews specifically because they are so
good with this deal you get 150 bucks
off when you go to teeter calm / Ben you
also get free shipping free returns
60-day money-back guarantee so if you
don't like it you're not gonna be
spending any money on it remember you
can only get that new 2019 teeter Fit
spine inversion table plus a free pair
of gravity boots by going to teeter comm
/ Ben that's te e ter comm / Ben again
teeter com / Ben go check it out right
now teeter com / Mann for the special
deal which includes 150 bucks off among
other goodies so go check that out right
now okay so what are Democrats going to
do to respond to president Trump's big
address this evening well they're saying
that they should go back this is the you
watch the new wave of democratic talking
points is going to be that president
Trump should just go back and sign the
2013 immigration gang of eight bill now
that bill was so bad that Marco Rubio
senator Rubio who was one of the
original sponsors of that bill backed
away from it in 2016 when he was running
for president and a little bit before
saying it was a mistake to have ever
signed onto that bill Democrats however
are trying to revive that bill why cuz
it got 68 votes in the Senate and it was
stopped by a Republican House 14
Republicans voted in favor of that 2013
comprehensive immigration reform bill
Senator Joe Manchin of West Virginia he
was out there saying that this is what
Republicans should do they should bring
back up that bill because that bill at
least had some money for border security
all it will take is you know amnesty for
11 million illegal immigrants we're
going to have to secure the border we've
always said that you go clear back to
the 2013 immigration reform bill that we
did in the Senate and we passed it with
a majority of Democrats and Republicans
think of as 68 votes it was a tremendous
piece of legislation if the president
would say this Chris we're going to
bring that 2013 immigration reform bill
back up within the 30-day trial period
within 30 days it has to be voted on
cannot be filibustered cannot be blocked
out we're going to have to take a vote
on the floor if he would do that he
would get what he needs
okay Jeff Merkley you making the same
point Democrat from Oregon he also wants
the 2013 bill this is gonna be the new
democratic talking point it's gonna be
well if Trump really wants border
security let's just do a comprehensive
solution now Democrats constantly want
to talk comprehensive solution because
they don't like the idea of bifurcating
the issue the issue should be bifurcated
what we do with the people here has
nothing to do with securing the border
nothing okay why we are tying
citizenship for the people who are
already here to securing the border to
prevent new people from coming in is
beyond me I mean honestly it's like
somebody somebody breaks into your house
and you have two things to do one deal
with the person in your house and to
make sure that the lock on your front
door works from now on these are two
separate issues
you wouldn't say you know what can't
deal with the lock on the front door
until we deal with this person in our
house can't do it we got a
with both of these at the same time you
actually have to deal with each one
individually right you have to fix the
lock on the front door which is one
problem and you have to deal the person
in your house which is a second problem
all right these are both problems but
they are not related problems and the
fact that everyone keeps trying to tie
them together is demonstrative of why
the government fails the government
likes passing thousand-page bills that
are packed with crap and then suggesting
they've solved the problem when indeed
they've solved nothing they tried this
back in the 1980s they declared amnesty
they said it would be the last amnesty
obviously it was not but here it's Jeff
Merkley claiming that the Republicans
should bring back up that terrible 2013
bill well in 2013 we had a comprehensive
immigration bill a number of folks have
tried to say to the administration we
have a broken immigration system let's
fix it let's have a bipartisan bill like
the one that passed the the Senate and
would have passed the house if it'd been
before but it was Republicans who
blocked it but as time as well I mean we
are happy to provide money for border
security that isn't the issue so this is
gonna be their new talking point is
let's go back to that 2013 bill you know
when when Democrats around the
government let's go back to let's go
back to that bill when it was not Mitch
McConnell in charge let's do that that
led to by way Mitch McConnell opposed
that bill right Mitch McConnell and and
the Republican leadership opposed that
2013 border bill why because that border
bill was filled with with amnesty for
11.5 million illegal immigrants as of
January 2011 it's actually a low number
it would have created a registered
provisional immigrant status that would
grant travel and work authorization
similar to the temporary resident status
of 1986 it would have streamlined the
naturalization process for unlawful
immigrants it would have said that
anyone whose presence in the US honor
before December 31st 2011 would qualify
for an amnesty which would create a
massive opportunity for fraud and how
about that border security right you
hear the Democrats here saying if we go
back to that 2013 bill there was border
security in it except for not except for
not okay what this bill did was it
suggested that the Department of
Homeland Security would have to commence
the implementation of asic of a southern
border security strategy and fencing
strategy before the secretary could
begin processing applications for
amnesty okay do you think under a
Democrat that lasts for five minutes all
that would happen is that the Democrats
would just declare that the border is
secure look we have a new strategy our
strategy is
borders secure go ahead and process all
the amnesty this is why the only thing
that matters when it comes to president
Trump's overall immigration policy is
the stuff that cannot be undone the
president can do a better job of
deporting folks that's fine the
president can change the status with
regard to e-verify for example he can
push harder in certain areas of
immigration enforcement but Democrats
can undo all that stuff what Democrats
will not undo they're not gonna go to
the desert and start digging up steel
slats that have already been placed down
it's one of the reasons why when the
Trump administration declared that it
was moving the US Embassy in Israel to
Jerusalem you know there are folks like
me he's hanging to the Trump
administration get that sucker built now
before the Democrats simply recant the
opposite recant the statement and the
same thing is true of the wall the wall
cannot be undone once it is done which
is one of the reasons Democrats are
fighting it so hard and why they're
pushing for the 2013 bill which would
not have included a wall either it
really is amazing so what what is the
other angle the Democrats are taking so
angle number one is they should they
should take border security without a
wall we don't want a wall okay that's
gonna be a hard bed honestly it's gonna
be an uphill climb for Democrats cuz
most Americans understand on a gut level
that walls do exactly what walls have
always been designed to do oh by the way
it is it is pretty incredible to watch
as members of the comedic the the
so-called comedic community try to weigh
in on all of this it demonstrates that
no one can actually defend the Democrats
program on this no one can actually
defend the Democrats program that a
border wall or border security doesn't
matter
no one Seth Meyers tried to do it all
right Seth Meyers last night he again he
spent all of his time going after the
the suppose in fact lessness of the
Trump administration rather than talking
about the fact that a wall would
actually be a useful thing capable of
telling the truth he shouldn't get to
address the nation just to repeat his
lies if he calls up the networks asking
for airtime they should pick up the
phone and say President Trump we don't
know who that is okay first of all I
don't know what happened to comedy and
as I mean close to comedy from Seth
Meyers but this is what the Democrats
are afraid of having to defend their
positions it is that simple so force
them to defend their positions instead
the Democrats are swiveling so they
swivel to the 2013 immigration bill and
now they are swiveling to the argument
that President Trump is an unprecedented
threat to national security
I'll explain why they're saying
and I'll also explain how President
Trump should respond to that in just a
second plus Bill DeBlasio now claiming
that he wants nationalized health care
in New York City but he doesn't know
what he's talking about
as per our usual arrangement get to all
of that in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that you've racked
up some credit card debt so for decades
credit cards have been telling you to
buy it now pay or pay for it later the
only problem is those interest rates
rack up unbelievably quickly well with
Lending Club you can consolidate your
debt or pay off credit cards with one
fixed monthly payment since 2007 Lending
Club has helped millions of people
regain control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards just go to Lending Club com tell
them about yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
accounts in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued all
you have to do is go to Lending Club
COMSOL Ashman you can check your rate
minutes you can borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club comm slash pen don't
let that debt spiral out of control I
promise you you're not gonna want to pay
that thing down Lending Club com /ban
all those made by web bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender it is not
responsible to allow your credit card
bills to continue to rack up those
massive interest rate charges instead
look to consolidate that's at or if you
just need a swing loan for construction
or something Lending club's the place to
go Lending Club com / been checked out
right minutes borrow up to 40 grand
again that's Lending Club com / man ok
we're gonna get to the Democrats claim
the President Trump is an unprecedented
threat to national security because he
wants to build a wall or something where
you get to that in just one second first
you have to go over and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can get the rest of
this show live and get the rest of
Andrew Clavin show live and Michael
Moses shall live more importantly than
those other shows income more
importantly is that when you subscribe
you now get two additional hours of me a
day we're basically doing two shows a
day right we do the podcast and then
later in the afternoon like 1 2 3
Pacific time we do our live radio show
and that means that you can all you can
either listen to it live on the radio or
you're not you're working at that time
instead subscribe you can actually see
the show we're gonna start taking
questions during the breaks at some
point in the very near future so you can
correspond with me in the middle of the
show
it's awesome ok we had thousand
literally thousands of people watching
us live behind the paywall yesterday you
should do that too because it's just
great go check it out for $9.99 a month
for $99 here you get all
that great stuff plus you get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels
looking at the leftist years hot Oracle
tumbler magnificent magnificent hey you
get that for $99 a year so much good
stuff go check us out at youtube or
itunes our Sunday special this week with
Stanley McChrystal it was really good we
have another great Sunday special guest
coming up next week as we do every week
we have so many goodies for you all you
have to do is subscribe 99 bucks a year
or $9.99 a month go check it out right
now we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so even as president Trump rightly
claims that we do need some border
protection on that southern border we
need fencing steel slab so whatever it
is we need a physical barrier to prevent
people from crossing that border
illegally this is not really a very
tough issue the Democrats are claiming
that President Trump is an unprecedented
threat to national security why because
they say he is going to use national
emergency powers now as they said
earlier on the show it would be a grave
mistake for president Trump to declare a
national emergency and then use the
military to build the wall this is not
the role of the President of the United
States it is not a national emergency
under any interpretation of that of that
statute furthermore it relieves pressure
on the Democrats to do the right thing
now the cynical the cynical politico's
out there will tell you that what
President Trump is going to do is he's
going to declare a national emergency
he's going to authorize the military to
build a wall somebody will challenge it
in court
it'll get struck down and then Trump
will go on Twitter and fulminate against
the courts and Democrats and then sign a
bill that just funds the government we
all move forward with nothing haven't
gotten done that would be a grave
mistake by the president it be a serious
mistake by the president it would be an
overreach it provide the precedent for
Democrats to do the same thing with
national emergency powers again as
somebody who believes in the structural
Constitution as somebody who believes
that the President of the United States
was not invested with these vast
overarching powers it disturbs me that
the president used national emergency
powers to declare tariffs on various
nations around the world and it disturbs
me that he would do the same thing to
build a bore wall and congressional
Republicans should not allow him to
congressional Republicans should be
fighting tooth and nail to get him the
funding that he needs to build that
border wall but you can see again the
big mistake here for the Trump
administration would be allowing
Democrats to misdirect either to
falsehoods told by the Trump
administration or to the national
emergency powers question both of which
the Trump administration is not correct
on the Trump administration should play
it straight down the middle
they should just say here we want a wall
Democrats won't give it to us that's
their problem
Ted Lou you can see where Democrats are
going with this Ted Lou the horrible
Congress person from California he says
that President Trump can't use national
emergency powers that would be
unprecedented it's my opinion that it
will be illegal for the president to use
in the Latorre to go build a wall simply
by declaring a national emergency
violate the pasta commentator's Act the
militant members would be far
in a legal order subjecting them to
being at risk of violating federal crime
this is a very big deal I hope the
president does not declare a national
emergency to build a wall okay well the
Democrats we want to focus on this as
opposed to the wall itself again because
the wall argument is not cutting in
their favor you can see this is this is
the pitch the Democrats want to make
Trump's an unprecedented threat to
national security just look at him
trying to expand executive power now
notice that none of these Democrats were
whining about President Obama expanding
executive power they were fine with that
this is one of the things that bugs me
about partisan politics Democrats who
are fine with expanding executive power
so long as their boys in the White House
and then Republicans were fine with
expanding executive power so long as
their boys in the White House as long as
your boys in the White House you're cool
as long as your boys in the White House
you are fine with the White House
expanding its powers right that's that's
absurd
okay and it's a problem people who care
about the Constitution should care about
the checks and balances of American
government with that said Democrats who
are suddenly proclaiming that they're
very afraid of the centralization of
governmental powers in the executive
they don't have a lot of leg to stand on
here angus King the senator from Maine
he came out he said Trump is what the
founders were afraid of if you go back
to 1787 the Federalist Papers the
Constitution this is what they were
afraid of what would what were the
framers afraid of that we're seeing
right now a monarch achill president
they took such care to divide power and
to allocate powers between the Congress
the president the courts and here we are
with the president that's trying to end
run the constitutional process or at
least his thinking about it if he wants
to enact some kind of policy it's got to
be through the Congress he doesn't seem
to get that okay I agree with that but
where were all these people when Obama
was president where were all these they
weren't anywhere every time Democrats
take power then we start worrying about
the legislative overreach and the
terrorists in Congress remember they
were calling on the tea party terrorists
in Congress and every time Republicans
president then we worry about
centralization of power in the executive
branch you hear Nancy Pelosi doing the
same thing to Speaker of the House she
comes out and she says you know
President Trump wants to abolish
Congress that's what he really wants to
abolish house she says this literally
three years after Barack Obama declared
he could unilaterally suspend
immigration law to legalize millions of
illegal immigrants in the United States
explicitly at the
I'm saying he did not have the executive
authority under the Constitution to do
it but here's Nancy Pelosi declaring
that Trump is obviously the threat to
Congress our purpose in the meeting at
the White House was to open up
government the impression you get from
the president that he would like to not
only close government build a wall but
also abolish Congress so the only voice
that mattered was his own hey every
president wants to believe the only
voice that matters is their own but that
doesn't mean that is the only voice that
matters again Nancy Pelosi was utterly
silent when Barack Obama exacerbated the
problem of the executive branch it's
it's really maddening just as a person
who cares about constitutional
government it is maddening to watch as
the political parties completely
abdicate their responsibilities under
the Constitution the gravest threat to
the American Republic on a governmental
level has been the legislature
abdicating its responsibilities to the
executive branch since the advent of
administrative government's in the early
20th century in the early 20th century
President Woodrow Wilson declared that
we would have an administrative
government a government that was
administered by the experts and that
administration the administration of
government by experts that would make
the country better all you had to do as
a Congress was pass a vague law kicking
the power over to the executive and all
would be well
and people have cheered that sort of
nonsense ever since it undermines the
very fundamental basis of freedom in the
country and whether it's coming from
Republicans or Democrats it's a problem
the hypocrisy of members of Congress who
only care about it when it's a member of
the other party that's untenable
and really quite gross okay meanwhile
the Democrats continue to push forward
their own radical agenda the latest
radical agenda push is coming courtesy
of Mayor Bill DeBlasio in New York City
so Democrats are already looking at
nationalized health care they're already
looking at single-payer in fact the
House Budget Committee Chairman who came
forward today Democrat came forward
today and asked the Congressional Budget
Office to score the possibility of a
nationalized health care system so all
of us who were claiming that Obama care
was simply the first step toward
nationalized health care turns out we
were all right at the time and Obama was
lying at the time and Democrats were
lying at the time when they said no Bill
DeBlasio is leading the charge I do love
it when Democrats make promises that
they obviously cannot keep and then the
media just parrot those promises so
notice the the let's Chuck's to pose the
media's claim that President Trump lies
a lot about immigration with the way
that they cover Bill DeBlasio saying
he is now going to provide universal
health care in New York City so Mayor
Bill DeBlasio came forward yesterday
according to NBC New York and he said
that New York City will begin
guaranteeing comprehensive health care
to every single resident regardless of
someone's ability to pay or immigration
status an unprecedented plan they'll
protect the more than half a million New
Yorkers currently using the ER as a
primary provider Mayor Bill DeBlasio
said it's not health insurance his
spokesman clarified after the surprise
announcement on MSNBC on Tuesday morning
this is the city paying for direct
comprehensive care not just ers for
people who can't afford it or can't get
comprehensive Medicaid including 300,000
undocumented New Yorkers according to
his spokesman Eric Phillips de Blasio
said the plan will provide primary and
specialty care from Pediatrics to ob/gyn
geriatric mental health and other
services to the city's roughly 600,000
uninsured
he said the city already has a
foundation for such a plan a public
health insurance option that helps get
direct care to undocumented residents
but that option will be expanded and
supported with the addition of a new
program called New York City cares that
plan will roll out in 2019 and build out
over the next few years he said it will
cost about a hundred million dollars not
per year total about a hundred million
dollars New Yorkers will be able to
access the program through the city's
website or simply by calling 3-1-1 and
there will be no tax hikes to fund it
said the mayor it's magic it's magic
we'll just be able to pay for six
hundred thousand uninsured people with a
hundred million dollars total and no one
will have to pay for it
de Blasio said we'll put the money in to
make it work it's gonna save us money
down the line I love whenever Democrats
say something's gonna save you money
down lines like when someone sells you a
timeshare honest to god
Democrats selling you government
programs is somebody selling you a
timeshare have you ever been to one of
those timeshare presentations so my wife
and I when we were on our honeymoon and
we couldn't afford to go and do all the
activities in Hawaii we went on the
timeshare presentation and what they do
is they sit you down and they say do you
care about the children that you're
gonna have one day or do you care about
your family do you care about vacation
like are you a person who prioritizes at
the time you spend with your family on
vacation because if you do you have to
carve that out of your budget every year
right and maybe the best way to carve
that out of your budget is to dedicate
yourself commit right now that you are
going to get have the best vacations of
your life every year at this hotel for X
number of dollars you're like yeah yeah
it'll pay for itself and so they say
it'll pay for itself they say don't
worry it'll pay for itself because if
you spend a bunch of money on the time
sure imagine I mean if you had to shift
that vacation every year it'll be even
more expensive so it'll pay for itself
in like ten years
and like ten years it will pay for
itself now there are a very small number
of people who are very happy with their
timeshares most people buy it and then
they're like oh my god what did i do how
do I get out of this thing
hey that's Democratic spending programs
don't worry well nationalize health care
it'll pay for itself really how how will
it pay for itself somebody's gonna have
to pay for it and it's not the people
who are gonna be using the healthcare
presumably it won't be the health
insurance companies which will be
bankrupted by nationalized healthcare
the people who are gonna pay for it
are gonna be the people who are no
longer allowed to use private health
insurance or if they are allowed to use
private health insurance it's because
they're buying over the top private
health insurance supplemental health
insurance and doctors who are being
forced to take government cram downs and
all the rest
de Blasio says this has never been done
in the country in a comprehensive way
health care isn't just a right in theory
it must be a right in practice and we're
doing that here in the city so here's my
favorite part of this that's the entire
media report right where's the
fact-checking like a simple bit of
fact-checking say like a simple division
problem so he says it'll cost 100
million dollars there's six hundred
thousand uninsured people in the city of
New York 100 million dollars divided by
six hundred thousand people got 160
bucks per person so he's not telling you
that you're going to be able to provide
comprehensive health care for six
hundred thousand people at the cost of
one hundred and sixty bucks a head yeah
uh-huh that's going to happen yeah I
mean how much do you pay in health
insurance a month is it a hundred sixty
bucks I really doubt it it's probably a
thousand dollars a month it's probably
$500 a month right it's not it's
something more than 160 bucks forever
red but he's claiming that for 160 bucks
it's gonna take care of all the problems
in York City all will be comprehensive
universal health coverage amazing I mean
this is the equivalent of Michael Scott
in the office when it's when he's told
that he has to declare bankruptcy he
just gets up in the middle of the office
and shouts I declare bankrupt city if
that's exactly what Bill DeBlasio just
did he just got up in the middle of NBC
and he says I declare universal health
care you're like well how it goes with
magic with magic poof it's an illusion
Michael hey
that's all he has to do or the media
eated up where the factory where's the
fact-checking what are the fact checkers
to say is that really universal health
care maybe it's a supplemental health
coverage to get one preventative health
care visit we're gonna pay with it pay
for it with a hundred million dollars
everyone gets to go to the doctor one
time to tell them if they have the flu
right that's an actual proposal it's a
bad proposal it's an actual proposal but
I love that everybody just sort of
repeats out loud that this is a
comprehensive health care program a
universal health care program provided
to you by Bill DeBlasio it really is it
really is incredible so well done once
again media Corps who say that only
Trump lies Trump's the only liar
Republicans are the only liars those are
the only people who have ever lied truly
amazing a Bill DeBlasio is a real truth
teller we should we should definitely
get policymaking power to people who say
that they can provide you comprehensive
health care universally for a hundred
million dollars for six hundred thousand
people uh-huh sure okay meanwhile
Democrats are are now looking for a 33%
corporate income tax rate increase they
want to hike the rate from 21 percent to
28 percent which would place us once
again at the among the highest oacd
nations in terms of corporate tax rate I
love the Democrats come into office and
their first move is let's raise all the
taxes yeah you go for that it works well
for Walter Mondale in 1984 when he
campaigned on raising taxes try it again
let's see how well it works for you now
okay time for some things that I like
and then we'll get to some things that I
hate so things that I like today um
there's a there's a great new book out
by Brad Meltzer as you know I'm a big
Brad Meltzer fan he's a terrific
thriller writer he's written this with
josh mensch this one is an actual
non-fiction book it's called the first
conspiracy the secret plot to kill
George Washington which is all about
kind of the first assassination attempt
against George Washington really a
fascinating book Meltzer is a really
interesting guy and a real patriot yeah
he actually emailed me recently about a
an experience that he had with George HW
Bush when George HW Bush was ailing
Meltzer went to visit him and Meltzer
read him from one of his books about the
founding fathers and George HW Bush just
sat there and like literally for an hour
just sat there enraptured by the by the
greatness of the founding fathers
Meltzer someone who really respects that
if you read his children's books as well
which I've recommended on the program
before those are well worth that I
believe this book comes out today
so check it out right now the first
conspiracy the secret plot to kill
George Washington go check that out
right now it's it's again really
fascinating it's about in 1776 an elite
group of soldiers who are trained to
serve as Washington's bodyguards but
some of the men were part of a
treasonous plan and it's a secret plot
and how it was revealed again well worth
well worth it okay time for let's see
one more one more thing I like so I just
have to tell you this story because it's
fantastic I do love it when life
provides you with karmic justice and
this is one of those cases there's a
woman who is standing on her own waiting
for an uber in Rio de Janeiro and you
know pretty young woman in Pollyanna
viana nicknamed the Iron Lady as it
turns out she's a mixed martial artist
fighter and a guy who try a guy tried to
use a fake gun to steal her mobile phone
while she waited outside her apartment
block on Saturday night she said when he
saw him when he saw I saw him he sat
next to me he asked me the time I said
it and I saw he was gonna leave so I
immediately moved with my cell phone in
my waist and then he said give me the
phone don't try to react because I'm
armed
then he put his hand over a gun but I
realized that it was too soft to be a
gun it was just like a cardboard gun she
said I sat him down in the same place we
were before and I said now we'll wait
for the police because she just subdued
him grabbed the neck and beat the crap
out of him she said I was fine because
he didn't react after since he took the
punches very quickly I think he was
scared so he didn't react anymore I said
I wouldn't let go and then I was gonna
call the police he said call the police
then because he was scared I was gonna
beat him up some more he had to be taken
to a medical facility to treat his
wounds and then to the police station
where she filed a report which is just
awesome just well done by this by this
young lady that's that's great stuff
gotta love that okay time for a couple
of things that I hate
so how many people have to die in your
apartment before it's too many people
dying in your apartment this is this is
the question of the day a young black
man I mean I really shouldn't laugh
because it really is quite horrifying a
young black man was found dead in the
home of edy buck who's a 65 year old
white man and prominent donor to the
Democratic Party with an alleged history
of supplying drugs to young
african-american men this raises the
question if everybody knew that he was
doing this for years then why exactly
was he killing a second young black man
in his apartment allegedly according to
West Hollywood West Hollywood ville news
an unidentified black gun was discovered
at bucks Laurel Canyon apartment Monday
morning in West Hollywood dead from a
presumed overdose the name of the dead
man has yet to be released but the
outlets suggest this is something of a
pattern on July 27th 2017 26 year-old
Gama Moore was discovered dead at bucks
apartment the LA County coroner's office
ruled Moore's death an overdose caused
by meth a coroner's report said drug
paraphernalia was found in the home
along with sex toys and clear plastic
bags containing what was suspected to be
meth the LA County District Attorney's
Office declined to prosecute buck saying
the evidence was insufficient to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that buck was
responsible for the death and then bucks
attorney said that buck didn't have any
involvement in that death and then
there's another problem which is that a
second dead guy showed up in his
apartment whenever whenever says another
dead man shows up in your apartment the
another is the dead giveaway that you've
got a real problem in August 2000 18
excerpts from Moore's journal or
publicized in order to bolster a push
for prosecuting buck led by Mohr's
mother Latasha Nixon and one such
excerpt from December 2016 Moore wrote
that he's become addicted to drugs and
the worst one at that edie buck is the
one to thank
according to open secrets buck has
donated tens of thousands of dollars to
multiple Democratic Party candidates
over the past few election cycles
including Hillary Clinton he also ran
for elected office he supported a lot of
various progressive causes throughout
the year this is not to suggest that
only Democrats are engaged in this sort
of activity because obviously that's not
true but it is worthy of note that this
guy is a major Democratic donor and we
will see if the media coverage continues
to be as long and comprehensive with
regard to Ed Buck as it would be if the
guy were a Republican which I can fairly
guarantee that it will not be okay other
things that I hate today so I just have
to point out the idolatry that the
Democrats have for Ruth Bader Ginsburg
it really is something astonishing Roger
Simon who's a writer
at Politico hee-hee-hee tweet out a
picture of Ruth Bader Ginsburg who is
apparently ailing and he said if it were
possible would you subtract one day off
your life and add it to Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's life for one extra day of
good health if just ten thousand people
did this it would add 27 productive
years to her life I don't even what but
I don't even know is that a brainstorm
does he think that we have that that
life sucking machine from The Princess
Bride that we're gonna strap Wesley to
the table or take 50 years off his life
and then donate it to Ruth Bader
Ginsburg or is Ruth Bader Ginsburg have
like a room of young virgins in the
other room and she just sort of drains
them of their life force
hey I tweeted out maybe we should all
give a year to Ruth Bader Ginsburg amend
she can live forever
presumably handing down pro-abortion
rulings from now until the end of time
that'll be really exciting I imagine
that do you have that kind of idolatry
for anyone for anyone it's funny there's
a Midrash which is kind of like an
apocryphal Jewish tale about about
apparently Adam and Adam being shown
King David by God and Adam lived till he
was 930 years old according to the Bible
and he was supposed to live to be 1,000
as the Midrash says and he was shown
King David and he and God said this guy
is going to die in youth and Adam saw
that King David could become something
great he said well I will donate 70
years of my life to King David well Ruth
Bader Ginsburg is in King David and this
deal is not on the table and if it were
on the table and you were willing to
sacrifice 24 hours of your life for Ruth
Bader Ginsburg then I would suggest that
you probably have your priorities not in
order Ruth Bader Ginsburg is a human
being she's not a saint and if you're
willing to do that for anyone like of
all the people on earth that you do that
for that would be it if I were gonna
give a day of my life to anybody
wouldn't it be some kid with cancer or
something Ruth Bader Ginsburg yeah okay
it just all right I mean I guess your
priorities are your priorities I can
final thing that I hate so I discuss
this a little bit on my radio show
yesterday but there is a new a new APA
report out American Psychological
Association report out the APA is just a
pathetic organization I mean that
organization is a political hackery
organization par excellence
they've already declared that things
that are mental disorders are not mental
disorders specifically out of political
pressure with no evidence to back them
now they have declared the masculinity
itself
traditional masculinity itself is
unhealthy to people which does raise a
question if you're a woman and you think
that you aren't traditionally masculine
man maybe you're not mentally disordered
for thinking you're a man but if you
want to be a traditionally masculine man
now you're mentally disordered so if
you're a transgender woman or
transgender man mental disorder isn't
wanting to change your genitals or
anything the actual mental disorder
would be you wanted to be traditionally
masculine obviously the real problem is
that you wanna break rocks with a
sledgehammer um according to the APA
they are telling you people that
something is amiss for men and they say
that they that 40 years of research
shows that traditional masculinity is
psychologically harmful and that
socializing boys to suppress their
emotions causes damage that echoes both
inwardly and outwardly well it depends
on which emotions we're telling you to
be stoic about if we're telling you to
stop whining in the words of Arnold
Schwarzenegger in kindergarten pop
better advice never given then that
seems not terrible if we are telling you
that you should never express your
feelings and obviously that's stupid but
I'm not sure that there are that many
people who truly believe that they say
that stoicism is bad aggressiveness is
bad all these things are how do you know
that this is unscientific because this
team says it says in the APA report are
you ready for this it's an actual
sentence in a scientific report indeed
when researchers strip away stereotypes
and expectations there isn't much
difference in the basic behaviors of men
and women that's patently insane there's
not only no evidence to back that all
the evidence is on the other side of
course there are differences in basic
behaviors between men and women there
are different behaviors with regard to
sex there are different behaviors with
regard to marriage they're different
behaviors with regard to child rearing
and job prioritization there are
different behaviors with regard to
spatial awareness right there there's
just different behaviors and activities
associated with men and women because
men and women are different but
according to the APA if you train your
son to be masculine then this is really
bad so me telling my son that he ought
to be competitive that it's good to be
competitive so long as that is properly
channeled toward productivity that's bad
it's bad what we really need us to
feminize our boys we need to castrate
boys that's the only way the best world
is a world without boys we'll see how
that world lasts in the face of a world
that is unfriendly and chaotic
masculinity is what Taine's an
unfriendly chaotic world it's necessary
it's useful not only is it necessary and
useful trying to
Froy it is an act of evil transgenic
masculinity toward being a gentleman is
the task of a civilization but trying to
destroy masculinity in the name of
femininity is an act of evil and it's an
act of prejudice and bigotry as well the
fact the APA is saying this sort of
stuff is demonstrative of the fact that
you should not listen to the APA is
anything but a political body they've
undermined all of their own scientific
credibility with garbage like this all
righty well we'll be back here tomorrow
actually we'll be here back here a
little bit later today so if you don't
subscribe be really sure because we have
more coming up later today previewing
president Trump's speech talking about
some fascinating information on Middle
East policy and and student debt I've
got a lot coming up this afternoons
you're gonna want to be here for that go
check it out of our daily we're calm and
subscribe this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Alex and Garo Audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing